big big Star Wars guy most Star Wars
games that came out personally I was the
Knights of the Old Republic guy I beat
that game like 25 times yeah Darth Revan
favorite Sith of all time Darth Revan
was like the king badass and then in
Sith law you kill your master to become
a master Darth Malek who's the primary
Baddie after you escapes the ship while
you're being boarded by Jedi Knight so
you're like cornered by like 20 Jedi
Knights and Masters and so then he fires
on the ship as he escapes to just kill
all you know 20 enemies plus his master
now mind you don't know that first part
you wake up disoriented you know the
classic like here's your sword and then
you find out later because then like
Malik confronts you and he's like you
don't remember Master and then like you
have this flashback and it's like it's
wild but the Jedis try and reprogram
your mind because he's like he's so
powerful if we could only use him for
good and then you have the choice of
like become Master Jedi and save the
world or do I kill Malik and Conquer it
again just the force powers for
lightsider so lame compared to the dark
side Powers it's like if healing and
like Shield
so